how are you guys doing i am joined with
a very very special guest that i'm not
talking about
he is very special but we're talking
about
who is the inspector general of the
world uighur congress assalamu
it's a pleasure to have you it's a it's
a real pleasure to have you finally i
mean we you know sabor has said some
really amazing things about you and we
know the work that you're doing in terms
of the activism and indeed the academia
i mean this is a book of yours isn't it
yes
i'm very honored uh to have this
opportunity especially my from my uh
brothers and sisters in face my own
religion
talking about their brothers and sisters
and the voiceless people right now in
concentration camp in china
where they have to denounce their
religion
the coffee of qurans were burnt the
mosque turned in the
uh
bars
and
they see islam religion as a illness
backwardness
and they want to the chinese communist
regime want to rewrite the quran openly
telling a chinese version of islam
and in this time
uh
to have you now in your show like your
brother
and it's very honor just for me like
uh who has uh doesn't know if
my father
mother or my sisters and the brother
alive or not almost four years
i'm not only one i'm one of the hundreds
uh thousands of weaker people around the
world in diaspora
we go in the bed you know without
knowing knowing our loved one is still
life or not our sister is raped or not
our children you know raising an
atheist system and these circumstances
uh we in diaspora so we were people left
alone
and uh we need you know like a like a
talk like this and that did give us you
know hope
and
uh
i'm very uh happy
to be with you thank you well i what you
just said there really struck a chord in
my heart because it was something i mean
we've heard this before with dr borhan
haven't we i know it's just so painful
to hear so it makes me
like the emotions it stirs within me
when someone says this to me is you feel
sad you feel sorry but then you feel so
angry as well don't you just knowing
that there are people out there
that are responsible for this kind of
thing yeah you know i want to ask you a
little bit more about your story
tell us you've just said something like
i've never heard from that many human
beings in the world
even in the worst most affected areas in
the world and i've been
to bad areas most badly affected areas
i've been to cox's bazar seen the the
rohingya i've seen people in outer
sub-saharan africa i've seen people in
the middle east i've seen it but
many people don't not many people have
the same kind of thing that they can
tell me that they don't know where their
family are still alive or not
when was the last time you spoke to your
parents
last time i spoke my mom 25th april
2017.
i have a open letter to my mom end of
this book
and
you know uh
what
every day uh if i pray whatever do i do
i i tell you know allah
have mercy on uh living on our debt yes
if they did allah bless them if they're
alive allah bless them that is the pray
right now you know
as we were muslim uh we are doing uh
right now and
i want to tell uh one simple story
the chinese communist regime
if they put
a person in concentration camp
this now because i interviewed some
campus survivor for this book they put
in this video continue this is a book
that you can get online yes uh it's in
amazon it's called menace
yes you get on amazon yes okay there is
a kindle version tour and
you can download worldwide and they if
they put in the jail first time they
tell them you know
they will
tell them you are here
nobodies no you are here
your relatives don't know you are here
even
your god doesn't know australia you are
here
if he knows
he should come
pick
you up
this is this is
this this attack is this they have no
idea
yeah they have no idea how that word
will come us to want them did they have
no idea how that word will come back to
haunt them that very word
yes it's it's comical that the the
atheism leads to them to this kind of
foolishness yes and sorry sorry to
interrupt you but i have to make a
comment about this really
it shows you
for those individuals who say that
atheism materialism all these kinds have
nothing to do
with
on the ground stuff these guys are
attacking religion
on on atheistic grounds your god doesn't
what have you got so why is he bringing
theology into this yeah absolutely as
you'll find in his book the
concentration camp survivors
give a detailed account what happens one
of the uh survivors uh sister zuma dawud
who uh i interviewed previously as well
she said on the first day when you're
there they teach you that there is no
allah like that's part of their
curriculum why is that why are they so
angry about the theology
well i just wanted to so in association
they have built these camps they've
built these concrete prisons they have
spent millions of pounds and they have
erected these structures in east
turkestan because the people refuse to
give up
that's why they exist because if the
uyghurs gave up
there would be no need for these camps
so these camps exist because the people
refuse to give up islam if you're if you
look uh
i will cut you will cut
there are a 1.4 billion people living in
china
and that we were muslim uh what the
chinese in their statistic it's always
the lowest they say 12 million uh we
were muslims
with the kazakh as other turkic muslims
maybe you are we are 15 million muslims
they couldn't
eradicate our religion or culture last
17 70 years
we you know they they this is not the
first time they burnt a copy of korans
they burnt a coffee of qurans and then
greatly forward in 60s culture
revolution in 70s
they you know destroyed the mosque at
that time even look in kashgar is it
like a bohara or samarkand the ancient
city in central asia where the madrid
you know for the theology for islamic
religion
very famous city
they left there in the
end of seventies
two mosque in in kashkar
but
we as a we were muslim you know we get a
little bit
uh
of a little bit tolerated freedom we
built our mosque
we you know get our religion again yes
and
our religion islamic religion
saved us
to become kafir or like a high chinese
atheist imagine that islam
saved we were people
in
1.4 million
people's around
and that's the why why why they
attacking the religion they say you know
to assimilate them to educate them
i have to take their belief their faith
i attacked them their face diminish them
you know and that's to do what they
attach and and this is this is not just
a war against we were muslim that's the
war
against islamic belief on faith
the islamic faith is not just belong to
we were muslim it's about the old umba
islami yes quranic is not the book holy
book for the uyghurs
it's the book for all muslims
and the masjid is masjid allah
house of allah yes if they be turned in
the bar okay we are just responsible
what what we can do
for this is every muslim believer is
responsible
stand against
this
war and faith
war against islam yes you know this is
something very important the chinese
communist party says this is an internal
matter
we say anybody that says
and you oppress them this is not an
internal matter this is a matter that
goes and reaches the entire muslim world
so they want us to give up and say oh
here's the border so these people are
being oppressed don't worry about them
but if you look at what they're
attacking they're not attacking them
just being very good they're attacking
them because they believe in
allah now sheikh
spoke about you know the destruction of
the mosque the desecration of the quran
all of these things the rapes that
happen in these concentration camps the
separation of children hundreds of
thousands of children separated from
their parents but here's something i
just want everybody to picture
they would put their filthy communist
flag above the name of allah and they
would allow the world to watch that so
if you watch the
mosque
in the edgar mosque that you have in
kashgar
this mosque it had bismillah rahim at
the front this is a few years ago and
you find many muslims praying there now
they've removed the name of allah and
they've stuck their filthy flag on top
of the masjid
and
everybody around the world sees that
atheism is above allah
from their perspective that they believe
that this is the way forward and we say
allahu akbar allah is above atheism
allah is above communism allah is above
the chinese communist party so their
message is clear
it is we are at war with islam that is
their message and in the other masjids
you find the actual picture of xi
jinping you actually find his picture
now we know the pictures are not allowed
in these masjids we know that you're not
allowed to have these images in mosques
and they've put his picture in the
direction of the kaaba
and even in some places they have made
their own chinese communist parties azan
they've actually made their own
uh sort of thing about the mother the
motherland and this and this muslims on
eid have to listen to the national
anthem which is full of obviously
communist ideology so as sheikh haris is
saying this is not an internal matter
anybody who says
this should make your blood boil yeah
make you understand this is our
responsibility i want to ask a question
okay
going back to your situation here i you
are the head
of the biggest congress isn't it and
mostly inspector general indian society
you are the inspector general okay of
one of the most if not the most
influential the oldest it is it's the
actual representative of the uyghur
diocese right isn't it right so
what can we do on the ground this is my
question to you what can we do on the
ground uh
i am the general inspector of the world
world congress which is the umbrella
organization for the weaker people in
diaspora
we
our
member our leadership will elected by
the delegation delegation will be
elected by the people of estranis living
in the diaspora and three countries
we had last month's every election
for delegation for the next congress we
have in the 12th to november in prague
uh we here we are elected freely our
delegation it will be held in the next
congress
it it means the world iran congress is
represented in the old issue in the in
the world like a like a exiled
government or representative
so so this is quite a big thing big
things yes and we have local
organization and then in the uk and
europe and america and everywhere
and uh this is a like umbrella
organization
so
for your question what can be done yes
our our uh problem is not in western
country in western country there will be
reports about
we were a genocide many uh parliaments
you know declared it said we were
genocide and it will be held right now
here in the uk
our problem is to reach out our brothers
and the sisters in islamic countries
we asking them not you know fight for us
we asking them just pray for us
like every muslim pray for palestine
for the every muslim you know depressed
everywhere they praying for them we want
you know a part of this
we are there for a part of this yes we
want to just you know that our brother
and the muslim just pray for us and we
have difficulty
to reach out islamic countries
uh many reason maybe you know that where
we have
chinese influence on that on that
but
uh we have still in islamic countries
many institutions
many influential people
imams scholars i think we
we should reach to them through
uh the muslims living in western country
because
as a muslim
in western country
we have luxury to get information
but this luxury
make us
to inform
to inform responsibility to inform our
brothers and the sister islamic
countries what's happening there yeah if
they don't know yes we can you know tell
them look just
in one month you know one uh
of a friday you know talking about we
were issue from just you know
perspective of islam as a brotherhood
you know as a part of a new man
we had we had um a protest as you know
in london it was probably one of the
biggest protests first july yeah first
of july and it was pretty successful yep
we've heard that it has actually made
the chinese government make amendments
even on the ground
in
uh in china in east turkestan they made
them people go to eat prayers and stuff
like that do you think
that activism protesting and these kinds
of things has an impact
and if so how do you advise us to do
this
yes
almost chinese government shutdown
mosque almost four years
last year nobody
got a mosque to pray for the idol
ramadan yes
but this time
after uh
first of july
when the our brothers and sisters and
face muslims
went front of chinese embassy in london
which is like a chinese foreign ministry
for the china yes asking them we are
here
we want
ask about our about about our brothers
and sisters in east turkestan we are
here maybe allah you know maybe there
were
thousand thousands uh the the people
attended this demonstration yes maybe
allah showed them thousands hundred
thousands allah they get they get scared
and then the radio free asia reported
yes the chinese communist government
forced
we were muslims
over 60 years old to gamas
the police went to every at home you
know you go musk the people are scared
so you're telling me it has a material
impact to actually change impact
because you know
the chinese communist regime is very
afraid about
pr
especially in muslim countries and the
muslims because
china's money came first from muslim
countries yes
and if they lose the money if they lose
the resource in muslim countries they
will lose everything
and it's crucial so this is working this
is working we have to say now and we're
going to mention this at the end once
again that we we are going to organize
another protest and it's going to be on
this with the second of november 12th
sorry 12th november which is the east
turkestan national day yes because in
1933 and in 1944 they had their
independence and it was crushed by the
chinese machine yeah
the chinese communist regime and the
12th of november in london and also
inshallah in other cities in the world
there's going to be a protest to speak
up for the uyghur people now uh sheikha
dries here he was speaking about
obviously the impact of that protest but
i would just i just want you to
highlight something
the chinese communist party you can
imagine as a narcissistic dictator
narcissism would not allow you to take
any criticism they cannot take any
criticism
and especially if it has to do with
money because it impacts them so even on
social media tweeting
making videos talking about it
that has an impact which is tangible the
protest definitely has one if you're at
home share this video tell your friends
and families about it go to your local
imam and say why haven't you spoken
about the ui people because i want
everybody to remember something
turkestan the land of turkistan which is
an ancient land of islam
this land became muslim over a thousand
years ago
and in this land we've had
from this land
people who've come to defend the holy
lands of islam like sultan kutuz from
egypt he was from turkestan barbara from
uh the mughal empire who established the
mughal empire he was from turkistan
who defeated the romans and actually
conquered the roman emperor was from
turkestan and then of course the
ottomans the cell jokes
yeah oh
and what we need to understand is islam
has been supported has been given
support from
turkistan for hundreds and hundreds of
years now they need us
now they need our help and they have
been islamists
foreign
which i think is a very important point
and i want to put it to you as well
uh you said something to me which i
think
was such a profound point that it should
be on the public record
you said you know of all of the the
causes in the world you mentioned
palestine you mentioned
like the rohingya like there's so many
horrible especially muslim-related
causes like humanitarian causes
you you once said something to me which
really stuck you know which is that the
weaker cause
of all of those causes is potentially
one of the most solvable causes
because
it's you know with the palestine issue
for example the superpower is against us
the superpower is in bed with israel
they and not only is the superpower in
bed with israelis it just seems
impossible to get the you know the the
objective met really unless something
dramatic happens absolutely dramatic
whereas with this situation here it
seems to me that because the powers that
be here the superpowers the hegemony the
the british
not british sorry the american hegemony
is
fair enough in an interdependent
economic relationship with china because
they both need each other economically
but at the same time
they are in a pr kind of cold proxy war
yeah this could actually work
there could be i believe that if we put
enough pressure on china it doesn't have
to be military pressure it really
doesn't i think
economy motivates these people like you
said if it gets bad enough for these
people they will stop doing what they
are doing i genuinely believe that
alleviation of this situation can happen
with a lot of international pressure and
pr alone
pr with with a robust economic strategy
as well which can be generated from the
pr can alleviate the situation to a
point which is completely
indistinguishable from what we see at
the moment do you think this is a fair
representation yes it's a fair
representation and
as i said before you know uh the first
of july impact yes and uh we are talking
right now
again at 12th november yesterday
national day
because this is
national day if you look back
the the the islamic republic of eastern
you know islam yet
you know this is the islamic uh
symbols and they ended
establishing this republic there and
this is the day you know 12th of
november yes to go out and just stand
you know for your brothers and the
sisters in the historic stand say we are
here we are hearing your voice you have
to
this is this is allah important and may
i finish this yes right now we are
working uh for that 12th of november
just you know in the us uh and then
australia canada and europe and the uh
everywhere
just as as a muslims
as a muslims as a umma
go to the front of chinese embassy
and ask
your brothers and sister and stand for
the justice yes that's the crucial
crucial we do it for every other we do
it for palestine yes and we see the
numbers for palestine cause this is
important yes and palestinian blood is
not more valuable than weaker blood this
is a this is a fact and also i just
wanted to say that you know uh the
sheikh spoke about the 12th of november
and that you know
this is an islamic cause this is not
some some something that muslims should
shy away from
east turkestan was the first islamic
republic in the history of the world the
first before any other islamic republics
and even if you look at the the people
that the old pictures of who's there you
will find that there is a lot of islamic
symbolism a lot of islamic slogans even
when for example the uyghurs when they
are you know they are representing their
calls they will say
dinam islam military
turkish
[Laughter]
when i looked at this i said this is not
a secular slogan this is not a slogan
about you know
communism the uyghurs are muslim this is
their slogan they believe in this and we
all know we all know that in islam
if we do not help each other then one by
one they will pick up each one allah and
this is the thing you know uh sheikh
haitham uh when he was speaking about
the course he narrated a narration of
the prophet sallallahu and i'm going to
paraphrase it that if we do not help a
person
and they are in a difficult situation
then it could be that allah puts us in
that situation because we could have
helped him we did it
so what is to say the whole muslim world
is silent on this issue
and then one by one china does this to
each muslim country
you know it's uh this is something i
heard from one uyghur activist and this
wallahi stuck in my head
east turkestan is islam's eastern
fortress
if that falls is game over that's your
first point of stoppage and what is it
what's what's being required just
activism
and just in the same way that
israel stopped his actions in the recent
conflict because of the outcry
same way the chinese they'll give up
they will give up they'll give up
they'll be like worth it for them it's
not worth it by the way
what the stakes for israel are different
to the states for china like you can
imagine china you know saying whatever
it's not worth it for us israel are not
going to do that they'll say we're going
to give up our country this is something
they've been fighting for years
for them it's different yeah and sorry
just to just to uh clarify we're telling
them don't genocide yeah so even don't
rape women yeah so when it comes to
israel or palestine
it's totally different because the
chinese call easter shinjang new
territory they know it's not their
territory that's what they call a new
territory two in their constitution they
recognize this an autonomous region so
meaning it should have everything except
foreign policy but it doesn't do that so
even the chinese regime itself it
understands this is not there's not the
land but they know it's not their land
but what we're saying is at this point
in time there are so many objectives to
be met before we're talking about this
land being independent yeah we're
talking about the genocide being stopped
the the concentration camps there's so
many things that can be improved
and it's
so many things that can be improved at
lower stakes yeah do you see what i mean
so i just feel like this is something we
we must like partake in and it will be i
think almost a form of discrimination i
must say if we if we
we show so much support to palestine and
palestinian cause which okay fine it's
the holy land is extremely important but
we show minimal support to the uyghur
people i just wanted to say something
that muhammad hadid he's one of the
volunteers for the uyghur human uh
weaker freedom organization he
you know he agrees with this even though
he's palestinian he said if the
palestinians
were sent over to east turkestan let's
say if the east turkestanis were sent
over to live in gaza to live in these
places right to go under the oppression
that the currently the palestinians are
going through
the east turkestanis would consider this
a holiday
the oppression in east turkestan is so
severe that if they went to palestine
they will say alhamdulillah this is all
right not to trivialize them no
absolutely not and and you know you're
absolutely right because someone did
point this out that we shouldn't
trivialize the palestinian issue but as
a palestinian muhammad hadid he said
look this makes sense
because the fact is if you're if you're
you know in gaza in in these and you've
done protests on this you know this
the killing and all of this damage
that's being done at least with your
family you know they're dead or alive
at least the palestinian children are
being raised as atheists there is a
different level oppression happening in
chinese occupied east turkestan that
actually makes other forms of oppression
which are horrible
look more timid and i think that's the
most extremely worrying thing about deen
there are five things that share came to
protect
the number one is
the protection of religion then is the
the protection of one's own self and
human beings so if we see a situation
where people's deen is being uh
changed forcibly because they're talking
about compulsion and religion talk about
islamic tropes and orientation they're
doing it they're doing they're forcing
people out of a religion
we're seeing that then that must be
prioritized yeah that must be priorities
and i just want you to add something the
numbers that we have in the uyghur
tribunal which is taking place this
weekend they're going to give their
verdict in december some of the
academics they're talking about hundreds
of thousands of children
have been removed from their parents
while their parents are alive and
they're being socialized into this
atheist ideology so it's not just to do
with a few hundred it's not a joke and
if you if you extrapolate that that
means and
this is not over hyping the situation
there'll be nobody to say
in east turkestan in the next 50 years
if this continues like this is what they
are planning to eradicate islam
from its very root but they have their
plans and allah has this plan yes and
this is how we have to get involved
we're talking about missionary work we
talk about apologetics we talk about go
and convert people and all that stuff
and people are being forcibly and we can
change it and so if we can't change that
then we haven't done our jobs like you
said it has to be fair
um and who would be most
qualified and advantageous in an
advantageous position to do so except
for as you mentioned the people who have
the most freedom we have the most
freedom yeah to do these things than any
muslims in the whole wide world yeah
this is the truth so it's upon us it is
really upon us yes and and uh look uh
this is not just the
tragedy we hold genocide or your issue
it's
as a
i i outlined in my book it's
all islamic issue yes because
uh we are just frontier front gate you
know uh to stop them there
because we have the knowledge we have
the experience we paid you know a lot of
uh
lives to get the knowledge how that deal
with them
if they you know
get
uh
eradicated estrogen and they will you
know will be in central asia
and uh this is the every islamic
country's issue you i'm
i'm i'm it's so big issue i'm outlined
in this book
i ask every
responsible muslim and brothers look
around him in his country where he is or
she is
look what the chinese
government or chinese business people or
chinese so-called investors doing there
they will find out
this is this is the the the forced labor
not staying in and then in instax time
they build them already in africa
thousands of thousands of publics right
now they're paying for the people there
to working you know minimum wage
few years later they will you know
cooperate with their military dictators
tell them bring people from the prisons
let them work for free
they will bear them for the prison to
work to forfeit if the prison is in
there they will you know make a new law
put the
young people in the prison
let them
bring to the forced labor this first
labor issue already almost in africa
i can you know
mention in this book some some some the
name of the country some politicians
and this is this we will tragedy
i am asking every uh my my brothers and
sisters not just as a we were issued or
we were uh problem we were we were it's
their own problem their country's
problems yeah you know sheikh hadri says
something which is very important yes
this is first and foremost definitely a
muslim issue however it's gonna affect
non-muslims it's gonna affect like you
said africa um it's going to affect
latin america it's gonna affect other
things so even though because we are
muslims and we are united and um is one
body we are speaking up but for anybody
who's watching this and if you're not
muslim this is going to affect everybody
you know this next couple of decades uh
what's happening to the tibetans what's
actually happened to the mongols in
inner mongolia so uh you know it's very
important that if we stand together the
mongols the tibetans the uyghurs the
muslims the the africans the latinos
because collectively they cannot take us
all on um i think uh just to end upon we
should speak about the world weaker
congress so the the the uyghur tribunal
taking place uh this weekend and you're
going to be giving a testimony there so
if you can explain about that please yes
uh inshallah it will be in the uh we
were a terminal there will be a victim
witness
the
the world had the chance you know to
hear
from firsthand from the victims
uh what they went to true from this we
were genocide and that is chinese
foreign islam
and additionally uh there will uh many
experts from a wide aspects uh giving
their their testimony in this genocide
and
i
was asked about
china's buying
muslim country's silence
and how they in fact impact on we were
genocide
and i i'll give my testimony there
already
sending this submitted report to them
it's
i'm not happy you know i i i'll give my
omission i'm not happy to give this
testimony
how the china bought islamic country's
silence i'm not happy to talk about this
because
it hurt me because i'm a muslim
i'm one of this ummah
and the
the pro front of the world you know to
tell look china invested there this
money
but this military guys or you know
corrupted this politician or but this
media and this media outline just you
know bring the news
from china as a miracle they're not
talking about the uyghur issue they
deport them we were students and we were
business people to china to
concentration camp it's not uh what i
enjoy to talk about it it hurts me as a
witness i'm very nervous brother to talk
about this issue
i wish you know at least uh that not the
case that's not the case i said one um
we saw you now as you said before as a
muslim um we you know a last piece by
peace and losing you know look
in the end
indonesia you know in central everywhere
yeah balkan kafkas and everywhere
we we have of course priority every
country but as a um
at least what we can do is what i say
inform fellow brothers yes that's true
and the mecca
that's at least what we can do it that
can do everybody that's the minimum and
also november the 12th is a protest yes
it's been a pleasure allah having you
and thank you you've given us the show
thank you brother